new developments in a story we've been
following now since last
summer attorneys representing the family
of jorge gomez the
25 year old who was shot and killed by
metro police last year
say they have new video now that
contradicts officers accounts of that
chaotic night
officers shot gomez during a black lives
matter protest that was back in june
hector mejia live downtown now with the
latest details hi hector
hey there and family members are still
here right behind me attorneys
representing the family held a press
conference here
in front of the federal courthouse just
steps away from where jorge gomez was
shot and killed
today would have been his 26th birthday
attorneys played several videos which
they say contradicts metro police
they added that gomez was not holding or
pointing a gun at police when he was
shot
that gomez was just trying to go home
after the black lives matter protest
gomez was openly carrying a gun and wore
body armor when he was shot
attorneys emphasized though that he was
exercising his constitutional rights
some accounts from officers said gomez
had raised a rifle toward them before
they shot him
19 times near the lloyd george u.s
courthouse in downtown
that was back in june metro officers
ryan fryman
dan emerton vernon ferguson and andrew
locker were involved in the shooting and
they are named
in a federal civil rights lawsuit filed
by lawyers for gomez's parents
just recently they added a fifth officer
john squail
to the lawsuit attorneys say squail shot
bean bag rounds at gomez before
gomez was killed he was added
a few days ago and what we're alleging
is that he's responsible
he's the one that set this the chain of
events in motion
right he used unnecessary or excessive
force against jorge
we reached out to metro police for a
statement regarding the videos in a
written statement they said in part
quote
the surveillance video released today by
the gomez family appears to be the same
video that the lvmpd gave to the
family's council
the video was originally obtained by the
lvnpd and is one piece of evidence that
is being evaluated
in the ongoing investigation and the
police department went on to add
asking people if they have any video of
what happened here again on june 1st of
last year
just as a black lives matter protest
crowd was disbursing
to share it with them reporting from
downtown hector mejia
8 news now